ciao a tutti benvenuti con anita vitale
hanno subito gli occhiali se andremo a
fare tre esperimenti assieme e quindi
tutto il proprio peso degli esperimenti
assieme parco degli strumenti fighissimi
che si possono fare in casa appunto però
vi consigliamo comunque di fare con il
misero sicuro che vi piaceranno saranno
super divertenti per voi e anche per noi
ma lasciate un po se volete vedere altri
movimenti dai fatti trucchetti da
soderbergh like
iniziamo subito con il primo esperimento
di presente sono prontissimo primo
esperimento è creare un suo no niente
cibo kata volta era un ologramma 3d è
presentato vai al chino e gli
occhialetti e medi ilfilm.it rete
creeremo lo stesso però il telefono così
ogni volta che volete potrete guardare
un mini film in 3d con ologramma nello
smartphone spaziale pochissimo una
bottiglietta d'acqua ovviamente dovete
far altro che c'è dentro
prima di utilizzarla quindi non
utilizzarla quota oppure per rendere
l'effetto ancora più spaziale
occorrerà una custodia amici di recchi
cd non so se ve li ricordate storia che
sono al centro due ore
il metallo canticchiate il compact disc
embrioni per volta per la finisco questa
andremo a distruggere 12 di via il
matrimonio di così che i nomi the values
è vuoto una custodia vuoto così davvero
quando per distruggerlo non serviva la
dobbiamo fare un taglietto qui proprio
sotto il tappo e uno qui dove iniziano
appunto le righe prima da letto fatevi
aiutare da un adulto ovviamente perché
soprattutto questa parte qui è molto
molto dura quindi primo taglietto si
rimuove il tappo seguendo nel letto la
lentezza della prima riga per ottenere
una specie di specie di cono poi andremo
a piegare prima metà è così
sul lato facciamo a primari aqua l'altro
francesi quindi abbiamo una meta del
cono originale poi andiamo a piegare
anche che premendo le due estremità
andiamo a parte le altre due sentenze ma
resta spingiamo bene bene così avremo
una specie di parla nelle ticket o
quadrato e come funziona adesso per loro
dramma adesso vi facciamo vedere ieri
ma vediamo prima il secondo metodo in
cui esse ancora più stratosferico se
invece vogliamo farlo con con la
copertina del cd
dobbiamo innanzitutto disegnare dobbiamo
prima di segnare dei tra pezzi di circa
8 centimetri di base per 6 cm di lato e
con un'apertura in superficie di circa 1
cm io ho fatto un trapezio doppio in
questo caso in modo tale da poter
ricavare due lati dalla dalla copertina
anteriore e poi gli altri due da quella
posteriore quindi provvedere poi compone
tirarli fuori
nel frattempo da questi due tra pezzi in
un taglierino e vado a tirar fuori e
utilizzerò questo cartoncino come guida
per tagliarlo poi sulla plastica anche
qui fatevi aiutare da un adulto
[Musica]
noi abbiamo il nostro trapezio
rovesciato che carino che poi farà parte
ii la questo mezzo di questo colloquio
adesso abbiamo il nostro cd qui
semplicemente lo apriamo solleviamo il
bordo di questo lato festeggia se avete
è uscito e poi per prendere l'altro
basta rimuovere questa parte qui da
piccolino mi divertivo sempre a
smontarli e rimontarli adesso rimettiamo
sopra pri e facciamo lo stesso con
questa guida che abbiamo creato in
cartoncino state molto attenti a
taglierino è ok adesso abbiamo inciso
perimetro di questa trapezio e adesso
dobbiamo semplicemente tagliare qui a
metà per avere le nostre prime due
facciate i primi due lati non dobbiamo
far altro che continuare a incidere
piano piano in attirare fuori due lati
allora una volta inciso basterà
semplicemente pressione
gentile perché molto tagliente ok allora
una volta ottenere poi i singoli la tv
andiamo ad incollare con del nastro
adesivo e ora finalmente andiamo a
provarli entrambi li andiamo a vedere il
nostro ologramma allora ora vi basta
cercare su youtube video per ologrammi
sul telefono se diete il video che
preferite attenderò tutto schermo e
alzate la luminosità al massimo voi fate
al centro il cono che avete costruito
d'ora per vedere il risultato dobbiamo
vendere le ips
guardate lo vedete questo un pokémon
vedete l'ologramma 3d bellissimo stampa
andando adesso guardate la farfalla mi
viene voglia di toccarla sembra vera
lissimo il cuore o il colibrì che bello
e rilassante
il pesciolino guardate sembra che sia
davvero dentro il cono la medusa è
bellissimo lo guarderei per ore mi sto
rilassando un sacco ora andiamo a
mettere quello fatto con la bottiglia
così vediamo anche la differenza si vede
anche un po con la luce
vediamo un po è una medusa è una meta
rossa che bello che sto rilassando un
sacco quale ho un pesce però forse un
paese
wow guardate tua persona che ballano
wow
[Musica]
guardate zoom in 3d purtroppo non
l'abbiamo fatto abbastanza alto e quindi
di taglia un po la testa però guardate
che carino
[Musica]
vedrete che caricano piantando mio
allora ragazzi per i maggior numero
[Musica]
allora voi questo esperimento andremo a
gonfiare magicamente dei padroncini
allora di cosa abbiamo bisogno di dover
correggere il fiore conosce già
verificato un altro episodio che li
accetto tipologia e di una bottiglia
d'acqua vuota del colorante alimentare
allora iniziamo con il primo palloncino
prendiamo la bottiglia d'acqua
orientiamo il palloncino di bicarbonato
di sodio che utilizzare un imbuto
riempie dei palloncini in modo tale che
stia tutto dentro bello pulito e
sistemato il tempo esisteva altro che
vado arrivati finora non esplode niente
quindi amo traffico come un punto paura
dopo la cottura che abbiamo riempito il
padroncino che abbiamo per metà ora
prendiamo la bottiglia e mettiamo
laccetto che versiamo la settimana
bottiglia ok è un po di assetto di gioco
di colorante tema halloween è ora più
sugli occhiali deve pannunzio sul collo
della bottiglia e ora giriamo aiuto 3
duro ma venderà perché settimana grazie
per scappare
ora abbiamo allegarla tiraccio di un
fatta ora rifacciamo l'esperimento bach
con un palloncino più particolare un
palloncino a forma di gatto
potete anche farlo con i guanti ho visto
questo esperimento che è fatto anche con
i guanti e il nostro punticino del primo
mozione perché carino allora riempiamo
il nostro gatto normalmente di
bicarbonato cosa cosa abbiamo
raddoppiato triplicato le dosi primo che
non rispondo ok andiamo a mettere
laccetto questa volta lamentiamo di più
perché amo quanto l'ho con chi ha storia
tutte le coppe
sceglierai indovina secondo me c'era in
allora per il colorante di speranza
verde no dai non poter calcare il verde
pesca con la pesca bello sto assistenza
[Musica]
canzone del sofisticato per il giallo ok
che trovo sarà pronto aiuto aiuto
occhiali
siamo d'accordo
no
a bollire della bolla ma basta mi chiamo
tantissimo stamattina gonfiarlo più
nostra faccia chi sta scappando
[Musica]
ok chiudiamo
ecco che un gatto è una specie di t però
tono sembrano tigrotto carino
allora vi è piaciuto questo esperimento
o valentino mi piace di più e skeleton o
il tigrotto allora terzo esperimento
questo esperimento più che essere un
esperimento è una sorta di fai da te
entriamo aprire dei bellissimi
antistress
allora vi ho preso tre palloncini
iniziamo con questo accordo la di
zucchetti la zucca la zucca allora
dovete credere un imbuto dovete prendere
dell'amido di mais anche con la farina
funziona però l'amido di mais e un po
più lunghi e non gradiente nel
palloncino e l'amido di mais ora
aggiungiamo un po d'acqua che ora che
cosa allora il nostro primo palloncino
antistress
pronto incontra palloncino distretto
abbiamo messo più acqua e infatti è un
po più stile stessi ball e brucola e
comunque super antistress tipo finire
ora andiamo a fare un altro utilizzando
un'altra tecnica e c'è andiamo
utilizzare la farina normale riempie con
la bottiglia di farina ok questa volta
gonfiamo il nostro palloncino
che cosa nostra abbia un cosiddetto
orsetto quando il secondo voi quanto
criceto no allora chiudiamo arrotoliamo
qua alla base proprio chiede ti piace ti
chiamano quelli la via del castoro e
sudore per il castoro rospi attacchiamo
palloncino alla base dell'offerta e
giriamo siamo tanto rumore ok abbiamo
riempito evoluzione di farina bisogna
mettere un pochino più di farina vediamo
ok di rete ci siamo ora appunto bisogna
sgonfiarlo pino che non togliete tutta
l'aria dal palloncino rimane solo la
farina cui potete richiederlo al 33
in questo caso è meno squeezable ed è
più switch morbido vedete non a liquido
dentro e fa un rumore rilassante anche
carino da ti piace di più il castoro
rosa la piccola ma questa qui al
pastello
una vecchietta che somiglia un po
effettivamente essi pistolino si vedrà
questo qui mi piace tanto si può più
riva stanza devo dire lo terrò del mito
per la mia scrivania non posso scusarlo
ciò che si gioca a jasper johns odierà
labbra era apprezzato più o meno poi se
volete potete aggiungere delle
decorazioni tipo i capelli qualcosa
contraddizioni da stante quanto sopra
facile accesso e cresciuto la pancia in
emilia è facilissimo da fare il film
carino e solo spostato da bari napoli
ritorna in base alla forma che gli
voleva anche che poi anche allora fateci
sapere quali finiti tre ferimenti vi è
piaciuto di più se volete consigliati
seppure nei commenti quali altri
esperimenti bolelli che facciamo nei
prossimi video e di riferimento capaci
sapere tutto nei commenti e ora vi
lasciamo qua 4 cappelline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
i nostri alte le nostre altri cialente i
nostri video divertenti video steve
cliccate su quella che preferite buona
nazionale